developers entrepreneurs designers and
all the rest please come a little closer
here's one of the secrets that we wanted
to tell you the keys to focus on the
long-term value of the users this is the
best way for sustainable profitable
businesses if there's one thing you
should take out from this lesson this is
it so we're done almost let's go just a
bit deeper here you want to avoid a
quick sell Netflix bass cabs and X and
many more are giving the user the
opportunity to try before they buy
moreover the let users use their service
on almost any device from any shape and
form this is another critical success
factor be everywhere one look at the
amount of devices that metric support
will reveal to you what we mean by
saying big everywhere